moi je peux plus voir ta gueule chez
d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salaberry
oui laurent laurent baffie que tu avais
tu nous lis le lot soit un grand bravo à
la chorale des ménopausées wawa cet amas
fa laurent battles qu'est ce qu'il va
dire quelle erreur peut avoir même pas
répéter badine ou sur toi oh bah oui la
vallée d'aure fameux m'a dit que j'ai
décoré ali il a dit madame il a du
sperme
[Rires]
tu as dit que j'avais des spermatozoïdes
c'est vrai tout ça mais je ne sais pas
il a dit c'est pas la meilleure vannes
heureusement qu'on s'aime bien on
m'avait caché la présence de laurence
commence à comprendre mais avait caché
les cherry dans sa nasse n'ont pas joué
sur laurent baffie en page web
[Applaudissements]
message la balance comporte sept m'avait
traité dans la rue tu feras tu pue du
cul ma mère ouais
alors messieurs
avant pour se chauffer on va faire un
petit prix de la tomate en perdent alors
on a le numéro de ma mère c'est parti
oliphant tu pue du cul c'est toi qui lui
fout c'est moi ouais les deux mois si je
peux lui par mois elle va me défoncer
mais ça peut être drôle si tu préfères
la défense et deuxième info deuxième
info léché turbo et du muguet a donné
l'info alors oui le muguet a mis le
turbo
vous avez compris le zoo je rappelle
jean codo photo chez vous aussi mes
chéris vous devez trouver l'info
correspondante oui chappatte à des
nuggets sur la [ __ ]
je vous jure que c'est vrai il ya plein
de gens qui pensaient qu'en fait je
voulais absolument que thierry ardisson
pas je vous le jure c'est faux j'ai tout
fait à tous sur internet
ouais franchement j'ai tout fait pour
que thierry reste parce que je voulais
absolument qui reste sur la chaîne est
gelée même appelé jusqu'au dernier
moment jusqu'aux derniers week-ends où
il a pris sa décision il a le moral a
gelé hier à l'ehpad la jeune scout yb
est français hester oui ça va ma petite
poulette du pdq
[Applaudissements]
toi tu es plus du cul esther tu pue du
cul tu es plus que toi même tu pues déçu
hester
[Applaudissements]
isabelle ltds promène sur la plage les
abel fr regarde un oiseau mort et
qu'elle ait fait ou ça parce que c'est
un numéro qui est un numéro j'ai
l'impression de stars à halo on sait pas
c'est peut-être bon c'est connu c'est
peut-être lui qui m'appelle dans mes
jolies parce que c'est un numéro genre
un peu comme envoyer sa numéro de stores
facile à retenir
c'est ce numéro soit ton chèque
la version de l'histoire s'il te plaît
mais je tout ce que je peux vous dire
que c'est pas celle là
[Rires]
jeux de mémoire et maintenant je vais me
faire engueuler je dis pas ça moi et
jouer je vais dit écoute
bonjour c'est laurent je croisais ben
non on avec deux buts ce qui peut
accéder c'est plus drôle mais où tu as
vu le sperme du prêt non il a dit ça il
nous le racontera peut-être une
cinquième place et sarah et rentrer dans
l'appartement une blague juive
oui elle rentre dans la bataille aura
sur le plateau qui se dessine maintenant
regarde le picasso y voit une tache sur
le picasso et se rapprochent picasso est
rayé ya marqué ça et comprend pas on
regarde le renoir en face il ya une
tache renoir est rayé ya marqué saravah
dans le bureau et regarde le van gogh
vincent mallet ya marqué sahara fait
david david questions avec les tableaux
fais ta gueule d'un contrôle fiscal
j'ai tout mieux tomber
nelson moi j'ai plutôt des émissions les
animateurs j'aimerais c'est quoi vachon
osent tout c'est toutes ces émissions là
le type eurovision télé réalité tu sais
ça voudra sourire je suis pas très fan
et toi lolo à moi je peux plus voir ta
gueule je décorais la pointe d'une
petite encore avant qu'on fasse le pape
qui est malade
1 1 il est malade alors les évêques qui
s'angoissent il appelle les toubibs il
trouve rien il emmène à l'hosto était
une batterie d'examens et trouvez rien
puis la santé décline de jour en jour il
ya un évêque fait les mecs personne
connaît un médecin un peu parallèle un
rebouteux je sais pas il y en ai vécu
six mois je connais un type qui est bien
il ya du pont coeur et les ventes alice
tout ça il a des résultats ils font
venir le mec et le sculpte le pape
pendant deux heures il est jeune
solution il faudrait qu'ils baisent
regarde on essayait qu'il faut mais ça
va passer à bouaye frais qu'ils vident
les couilles papale saluer remettre les
méridiens ça ouvrira les chakras ça
alors l'énergie reviendrai mais bon on
peut pas laisser crever d'accord on le
fait mais le chef des évêques fait à
trois conditions la [ __ ] faut qu'elle
soit aveugle faut qu'elle soit muette et
surtout qu'elle était très gros nichons
il ya un évêque fait pourquoi des très
gros nichons l'autre et parce qu'il
adore ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]